hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're talking about unique
creative ways to learn how to code
because
sometimes you got to spice things up a
little bit sometimes the idea of opening
a textbook for the 300th time
and going down your chapters or going to
these online courses is just not fun
and it's important to have fun while
learning how to code
and so yeah let's go into some unique
creative ways to
do that one of the things i highly
recommend doing
especially if you're brand new to this
is
opening up chrome navigate to your
favorite app your favorite sites your
favorite
landing page and then press command
shift c
if you're on a mac i'll check what it is
to do that if you're not on a mac
i'm thinking ctrl shift c but i'll
double check and i'll add the directions
below
but what this does is it opens up the
developer tools for you
now you're basically able to kind of
inspect
your page that you're on by scrolling
through with your mouse
the different elements and different
components on the site you should be
able to see
the code highlighted that actively deals
with that
and then if you want to really go into
something more cool
is you then can navigate to the styles
section
of the developer tools and see how the
page is styled and what's even more
interesting and more
just wild is how you can actually
change the styling yourself right then
and there you can be on facebook.com
and change a color from blue to green or
change the background from gray to white
and all of these things and it is just
so fascinating to see and i find
this to be a great first step for people
learning how to code because
it should get you excited it should get
you excited and should
be just so mind-boggling to you how
you're able to this
site that millions of people use all
around the world
here you are technically kind of
changing it up and so
that should provide you with the
motivation and excitement
needed to just carry you on through your
coding
journey and so that's one of the first
things i like for people to do one of
the next things i highly recommend
is going to kids games i know it sounds
weird especially if you are
an adult um doing this but
i think this is so great one of the kids
games highly recommended is one called
scratch i'll link it down below
but this is so great because a lot of
people's
hesitation when it comes to learning to
code and becoming software engineers and
developers
is the idea that they're not smart
enough they're not smart enough they're
not
skilled enough etc but when you see this
kid's game going on literally meant for
kids
it kind of dispels that it should dispel
it like well
there's these systems and resources
meant to help
children children and so what is your
excuse so what do you mean you're not
smart enough
if your eight-year-old in the back can
be up here putting h tags
and putting on basic sites and landing
pages
basically then what's your excuse so it
dispels that a little bit
and really helps again put the fun back
into things makes
things less intense of here's this huge
learn how to code in six month textbook
and
it creates this huge weight on you but
now you're just playing a kids game
you're just playing a kid's game and
learning how to
love this new journey you're on and so
i again will add the link to scratch
below and i'll add links to other
games um specifically kids games below
so you can test that out see
what you fancy most similar to kids
games what you can do is also play
video games this is great especially if
you already identify kind of as a gamer
especially some of y'all gamers you
don't need to read instructions
directions nothing
and then 20 minutes later you're on
level six doing all of these crazy
like i'm not a gamer and so it's always
fascinating
for me to see people act this way of wow
they just got the game and here they are
on level 99 without ever
looking up how to actually play the game
and so with that type of
being able to learn so quickly playing
video games
designed for learning how to code might
be the route for you
if that's kind of what you do anyway
with
other games and sports and things like
that one of the games highly recommended
is code combat i'll add the link to that
again below
everything i'm talking about i will add
the link to it below but yes code combat
i hear is great and so try that out
try the different games try the
different sites and see what meshes best
for you again is great for if you are a
beginner because again we're trying to
just just chill a little bit just be
calm with this be excited about this and
have
fun and so by learning these basic
fundamentals in a fun exciting new way
that really can be what helps us just
carry us along the finish line now let's
say you're a little bit more advanced
you're over here watching this like nah
this is not pertained to me because i'm
six months in
okay let's say you're a little bit more
advanced one thing that i
highly suggest especially to switch
things
up a bit for you is to contribute to
open source projects contributing to
open source projects is a great way
to learn in a basically a different
environment you're
kind of like learning on the job but
it's not a job because you're really
donating your time and your skill sets
for already existing projects out there
in the community
and so it really just tackles so many
things with you feeling like a great
person donating your time and skill sets
for these organizations for these
projects for these people
but also you are able to develop your
own skills being able to
learn how to start on a project that's
already
been going on before you even got there
because when you start working
that's how it goes the project has been
there and it'll be there likely
long after you're gone and so it's
important to know and learn
how to start in the middle of something
instead of practicing by constantly
building things from zero to a hundred
it's important to start at level 50
learn how to start at level 50 and take
it to let's say level 60 level 65
and pass it out and go to something else
and so contributing to open source
projects
is a great way to do this and if you are
looking to charge you know your job hunt
process and be
employed it's a great way to network
especially because with this
you're developing with other people
people who likely
have jobs jobs and established companies
established organizations
startups mid-level large companies
and now they got to work with you as a
developer
and so when it's time for you to start
looking for a job you have
people that you can turn to asking for
their advice for their insights
or they're the ones who have a job and
so they turn to you knowing that wow now
i really threw this down she really
was amazing at this and so let's see if
she would
consider working for us and so it's a
great way to just knock so many birds
with one's tone while also again keeping
things
fresh and interesting and exciting
because there comes a point where
opening a book just does not do it
anymore
i never like fun fact in my entire time
learning how to code i never picked up a
book because i am just not a book person
i need
exciting new interesting ways to learn
to code and so
that's hopefully what these are for you
guys i hope you
learned something here today i hope you
are
interested in seeing the different
routes you can take in starting your
coding journey or continuing your
current journey
or just switching things up in general
whether you started yesterday
or a yesterday a year ago so yeah just
breathe and just see something new and
let me know which
route you think resonates most with you
for where you are
right now in time and so please
subscribe and please like this video it
helps me out
so much so no thank you so much and i'll
see you all
later bye